there's I think a Sci-Fi series that I
have I'm very very excited about uh
and the reason was was because I was
like so staff for sci-fi that I was like
I'm gonna read books I'm I'm I'm
actually going to read well I mean
luckily we've had Dune which is yeah
okay okay
let me let me rephrase give me more
sci-fi that is not Star Wars I am
medieval give me a fantasy give me more
fantasy that is in Lord of the Rings
yeah yeah doing part two is coming out
um
yeah so me and the boys rocking up to
down too bro we're like
[Applause]
yeah a Sci-Fi series I think is in
production right now can you confirm
this Nabi is a series called the three
bodies problem or something like that
which was a Sci-Fi book that I was very
very interested in Reading
um but it's about it's basically like I
think the premise of it which because I
I've only read the synopsis uh it's
basically
um there's something that proves that
all of like all of the scientific basis
and all like the mathematic basis which
we base all of our Sciences on is has
been proven like false so Einstein's
proof of theory is false and everything
like that and then you just see uh and
then scientists uh [__] and then you
just see the reaction of the world where
the F where everything that we believe
is false and wrong all of reality on
Twitter yeah like Twitter so basically
this is a movie where if what what would
happen to the world if someone else
next year [__] yeah Netflix I mean I I
think the this doesn't mean anything
right now but the show the show Runners
for law of four Game of Thrones is
working on it so that that can be a yes
or a no okay okay I mean clearly though
you're the one thing you can't argue
about the Game of Thrones is and how's
the dragon team is that you know the
writing staff were [__] talented yeah
when they were in when they were
crushing it in the older Seasons yeah it
was [__] like some of the best
dialogue we've had TV for [__]
decades
um I'm really glad really really really
really really happy that Dune did well
because like as a movie you're watching
it you're like this is like the complete
opposite of like a Marvel film where
it's like they are entrusting you so
much that you will get invested in this
world that is so I mean Dune is like the
first 30 minutes are pretty it's pretty
dialogue intense oh yeah and so the fact
that something like that can do well and
be successful in this climate of like
Cinema where it feels that like that
wasn't kind of welcome it's so good and
the fact that a part like it's a part
one and I was just I'm just so glad not
to mention they took away again like as
someone who's read the books they took
away so much info from the books and yet
it was still cohesive I mean we've
gushed about how good doing this is I'm
just glad it did well and I really want
more I'm I'm really glad I did well as
well and I I think like you know my the
latest example I can think of is uh I'm
gonna go on from the tangent like
villain Saga season two yeah where you
know you look at Dune you look at
villain Saga season two where it's a
little bit slower than what you'd expect
audiences to gravitate towards but it's
a lot slower it's a lot more dialogue
more character driven but one thing
that's slowly been proven is that people
actually have patience if the [__] sure
is good man if the show or story or
character good people will have the
patience to sit through that because
everyone thought that everyone was going
to drop villain Saga season two because
it was the Farmland Arc it was slower
and then what's happened uh it's kind of
popped off it's because it's given us
one of the best memes and one one of the
most widespread memes in recent memory
with like you have no enemies I'm like
how did the meme from Finland Saga
season two out of everything pop off of
tick pop off from Tick Tock man that's
like that's the biggest plot twist of uh
from season one
[Music]
give us more you don't you don't you
don't need like [__] Subway Surfer on
give us some good slow burners man yeah
that's what I want yeah give us some
good dramas
it's a tough sell but you know if if you
know shows like Steins Gate has proven
anything it's like you could be slow as
[__] but if you put if you stick it
through to the end then every everyone
can agree just how good it is you know
and I feel yeah we don't really get that
as much anymore because is it because of
people having shorter attention spans is
it because of the tick toe generation
hard to say but let's just blame
everything on Tick Tock I
that's just a byproduct of what's
happening but like you know it's it's
definitely just like I've seen a recent
Trend at least with like films where
it's just like we're not really getting
as many other slow burners or they're
not getting it I think I think it's
because the the landscape of like going
to the theater has changed drastically
yes absolutely so you know you you now
have to make your money on a movie in
the theater world before you know your
DVD sales and you could rely on those
kind of kind of supplement things yeah
yeah and I think now you when you when
it plays in theaters it has to sell so I
it made this kind of and streaming deals
didn't really make much as we learned
from the pandemic because you know even
like Warner Brothers that made um made a
bat not bad woman Catwoman what is it
what's it called uh they made a movie uh
a DC I think and it was completely done
but obviously I think there's a there's
a weird tax kind of thing where if you
scrap it you can save money and I
thought it was it was just wasn't even
worth releasing oh really save more
money from just scrapping
there's some kind of tax reason where if
they scrap it or don't release it they
can they can they can they get some kind
of thing on it and so I think we're at a
point where
movies have to perform at the theater
and so street is taking less risk which
meant more movies that you were easily
marketable and easy for people to
understand yeah follow a formula less
risk-taking and then only sticking to
kind of like very well established
directors as well so we kind of you know
it it I think the reason it changes
because of that not because of uh not
because of Subway Surfers you know the
pandemic also [__] did a number on
film and theaters I I think I think it's
it's too easy to blame everything on
tickets I was just like I was just I
know I know I know I'm just saying just
in case the comments are going to go off
and be like shut up we know we're not
being serious don't worry okay I don't
know if this is going to be a hot take
or or not sure
I actually okay I want less things to
come out okay okay hear me out hear me
out okay I don't know because I'm am I
complaining about too much of like I
think no there is way more stuff coming
out that is true I mean there's like
five times the amount of TV series
coming out now yeah and it used to be
and and you know you you see this in
thought in the form of like every media
not just like TV series but like anime
as well I'm pretty sure like music and
like pretty much every form of like
entertainment and part of the big reason
for that is one the internet to the bar
of Entry to like make something is just
a lot a one nowadays
um but just means we get a lot of [__]
we get so much [__] to sieve through
it's pretty easy to shift through it do
you think so yeah it's gotten I think
it's gotten easier to sift through but
that doesn't really take away I guess
the stress of you know wanting to just
find something that is good and will
continue to be good right whereas like
you know back up when like those maybe
what like
15 20 anime made in a in an entire year
right like you know early 2000 [__] yeah
Boomers remember that how many new anime
released last season Joey
100. it's uh it is it was 55 I believe
yeah 55 shows yeah and two years ago it
was like 30. yeah like but like you know
you go back to like you know the early
to mid 2000s right when you know I
really started to kind of explore
everything like there was maybe only
like 30 shows to come out in an entire
year yeah so it was not only easier to
be able to look at everything and being
like all right what is it that I want to
watch what is it I don't want to watch
but now it's just like you have [__]
what 50 you said 55 you can't watch all
those videos no no no no that's if you
were to keep up with everything that's
watching two uh two entire Seasons worth
of anime every week just to uh just to
keep up with everything coming up yeah
yeah that's too much and it's just like
it's there is what like you just don't
have the time to watch or play every
video game that comes out watch every
movie watch every TV series
um I kind of but like
it just seems like sometimes
when you look at something like Netflix
and I feel like something like Netflix
is just pumping out just as much [__] as
they can they're just pumping out
they're pumping out stuff that I'm just
like this is this is like second monitor
[__] you know this is just [__] where
you I don't know what to watch because
there's so much so I'm just gonna put on
some just background noise yeah so I'm
just gonna put on some crappy reality
like dating TV show and then you look at
something like HBO where I'm like wow
everything you put out is a [__]
Banger and I wish there were more
companies like HBO that just were like
so dedicated to instead of like pumping
out as much [__] as they could just like
curate the stuff that you have and just
make it as good as possible because I
feel like there's so much mediocrity now
everywhere everywhere there's so much
mediocrity now
um instead of just focusing on like good
stuff that's yeah that is gonna like
stick with people you know yeah this is
tough yeah how do you do that in the age
of streaming where anyone you know you
can just upload everything uh yeah I
mean there's not really a downside to
having more programming for a lot of
these websites or kind of TV stations
and I think a lot of people as well will
kind of take your point and you know
make the argument of like yeah but you
know you don't have to watch everything
like you you can make a you can make a
choice to like see a trailer or
something and be like ah no I don't want
to watch it or you know I'll instead
watch this but like I feel then that
kind of creates the problem of you know
fatigue like we've been talking about
this entire [__] episode of like yeah
there's too many [__] Marvel films
and now I'm fatigued over it even if
fatigue yeah fatigue
um it sounds like that's like when you
play too much fatey
but like you know
uh I didn't watch every Marvel film I've
I haven't watched most of the Marvel
films but I still have fatigue over it
because it's just like I don't I want to
stop [__] seeing it even even just
even just like seeing it like just
off-handedly like even a trailer of
people talking about it or whatever I'm
just like all right I get it you know
can we can we actually like talk about
something for some amount of time before
we just throw it away and being like
let's this this new thing now you know
it's just like again like I feel
it's just you know and Anime is the same
thing where it's like it's not so much I
don't want to see these shows it's just
that I just can't see these shows
because I now I'm confused I'm like all
right well [__] now before when there
was only maybe five shows I actually
wanted to watch now there's like 50
shows I want to watch but I can't
realistically watch all of them yeah I
feel like people would just move on so
quickly now yeah like once you've
finished one thing you're like marathon
in a day and you're like that was good
all right time for the next thing and
yeah and you're just like there's never
that that like if you missed the
conversation that happens the week after
season finale is you're just never gonna
talk to it talk about that thing I mean
you know recent animes is a great
example of that of being like you know
it's so incredibly hyped up while it's
airing and people be like this is a show
that people are going to be talking
about for years to come yeah nine times
out of ten the moment the last episode
finishes everyone forgets about it yeah
yeah exactly right sometimes people are
like hyping up this new show it's not
just Anime but a week a week later the
new episode the new season starts and
everyone's like all right what's the new
shiny thing what's what's what's what's
uh what are we going to talk about today
exactly exactly I do miss the time
period where it did feel like everyone
had like a baseline of things that we
had all kind of like collectively
watched you know because I felt that way
not just with an anime but just like
just like with movies as well you know
if you find someone into movies you'd
have like you'd sort of had like a bass
line of just like classic movies that
everyone had seen yeah but now it just
seems like everyone has just random now
every every it's just [__] randomized
depending on what that person has been
recommended on Netflix or whatever and
like there isn't that same kind of sense
of community community like even with
just movie going watching where people
have like oh you've seen like the
classics right you've seen you've seen
these shows wait you haven't seen
[__] Terminator or Jurassic Park or
something like that you know what I mean
uh you know it would always start that
conversation but nowadays no one has
time to watch old movies yeah no someone
has time to watch the classics will go
back because there's just too much stuff
being made even though you should even
though Classics for a reason yeah yeah
yeah I I don't know I'm just I'm just a
boomer missing that oh man
missing your good old days exactly back
when everyone played you know every kind
of like back when everyone played the
same kind of thing back when everyone
was watching the same stuff playing the
same stuff listening to the same stuff
now it's just like it's harder to find
people to relate to because everyone is
because there's infinite possibilities
now of what anyone can watch and it's
like it's so hard now like especially if
you're not constantly watching all the
popular stuff you know that it's it's
very difficult to be like oh did you
watch that one show that I really
enjoyed and they'll be like never heard
of it yeah exactly